bonjour à tous honor officialisé en
chine son tout premier ordinateur
portable
le magic book et il se pourrait qu'il
arrive en france d'ici très peu de temps
alors vous allez voir c'est super
intéressant parce que ce badge book
ressemble énormément au macbook d'apple
est quand même pas mal de différences
on a regardé sans le regarder si c'est
intéressant si c'est un produit dans la
mesure où il arrive en france voir si
c'est un produit il faudrait acheter
qu'est ce qu'elle en vente qu'est ce qui
peut nous apporter et ça on regarde
maintenant
au nord est une filiale de huawei honor
est relativement fort pas se mentir sur
les smartphones d'entrée de gamme et de
milieu de gamme et là ils vont compléter
leur gamme maintenant avec des
ordinateurs portables avec en tout cas
un tout nouveau magic book
ça ouvre vraiment d horizons très
intéressant ce qu'il faut savoir que
coûte et chihuahua et vous avez
effectivement les smartphones tablettes
ordinateurs portables montres connectés
et tout un écosystème autour de la vie
numérique au nom pour effectivement
emboîté le pas et proposer des nouveaux
produits et notamment des ordinateurs
portables alors un macbook qui en tout
cas est vraiment super élégant ressemble
on va pas se mentir il est vraiment
inspiré pas dire pompe est très inspirée
des macbook
du coup le design est très bien réussi
l'épaisseur n'est pas là mais vous
apprenez quand même relativement épais
1,58 cm là où apple propose des produits
qui font entre 0,35 et 1,35 cm et il
pèse 1,47 kg pour être très précis au
niveau de l'écran en retrouve un 14
pouces c'est une dali psc du lcd
résolution full hd 1920 par 1080 de ce
que j'ai pu lire ci et là la luminosité
le contraste
ça serait pas particulièrement sain une
luminosité assez faible et un contraste
pas assez punchy
le châssis en aluminium donc d'un point
de vue esthétique c'est vrai c'est
quelque chose qui est vraiment bien
réussi côté performances on a la
possibilité de choisir entre deux
processeurs swan une telle core i5
cadencé à 1.6 guerre c'est que vous
pouvez monter jusqu'à 3 4 en mode boost
en mode turbo soit en intel core i7
cadencé à 1,6 ghz couplé monter jusqu'à
4 giga hertz en mode turbo vous avez
soit 4 soit 8 gigas de ram 256 giga de
stockage en ssd et aka graphics et une
nvidia geforce et mixant 50 avec deux
gigas de mémoire gddr5
niveau connectique usb type c de l'usb
3.0 du hdmi un port jack pas de port sd
une batterie de 57 4 watts avec une
autonomie annoncée entre 12 à 13 heures
il ya également quatre haut parleurs
dolby et moss pour une spatialisation du
son au tour de votre machine et un
lecteur d'empreintes digitales pour
pouvoir le déverrouiller facilement avec
votre doigt
côté tarifs s'il arrivait en france pour
les retrouver
la version i5 à 650 euros et la version
i7 à 735 euros
ces tarifs donne une indication rien de
bien précis comme je voulais dire pour
l'instant c'est un produit caa du tout
été officialisée en france il est arrivé
en chine
il se pourrait si on suit la logique de
développement au nord qu'il arrive en
france et qu'elle soit présentée en même
temps que le honor nice à savoir dans
leur présentation qui aura lieu le 15
mai prochain à londres
et du point de vue de l' os il tourne
sous un windows 10 alors comme d'hab
vous invite à rester connectés parce que
ce produit on va en parler je vais
essayer de pouvoir le tester pour
l'instant je suis pas encore mais on va
se battre pour récupérer tous ses
produits pouvoir les tester ensemble et
voir s'ils sont intéressants et pouvoir
comparer effectivement avec les macbook
moi j'ai un macbook pro qu'un petit peu
anciens mais voir si ce produit tient
ses promesses s'ils intéressant oui non
vas y a plein de choses à voir parce que
effectivement au niveau du marché des pc
il ya quand même
pléthore de produits on va trouver des
produits aux alentours des 500 euros
assez facilement
celui ci pourrait se positionner un
petit peu au dessus en terme de budget
avoir effectivement si c'est intéressant
par rapport à la concurrence
oui non pas mal de choses à regarder de
ce côté là en attendant sa probable
officialisation en france dites moi vous
ce que vous en pensez est ce que vous
pourriez être tenté par un pc de honor
est ce que vous avez déjà des produits
au nord c'est dans les smartphones ya
une gamme qui est extrêmement large
est ce que vous trouvez que c'est un bon
point que au north diversifie puisse
composer pourquoi pas à l'avenir des
tablettes il ya déjà des petits
bracelets connecter mon pour
effectivement imaginer des tablettes
dites moi si ça vous intéresse si vous
faites vraiment confiance à cette marque
et si vous la trouvez séduisante
suffisamment au point pour lui confier
votre ordinateur mark et moi tout ça en
commentaire comme d'habitude je vous lis
mes cd jolie pouces vous allez voir on
va en parler davantage ya plein de
choses à regarder plein de nouveaux
produits qui sont super sexy qui arrive
donc rester connecté merci à vous
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo comme
d'habitude vous invite à laisser des
jolies pouces a marqué toutes vos
questions suggestions tout un
commentaire et puis on reste connectés
parce que vous allez voir l'acte uteq ne
s'arrête pas sur la suivait à fond pour
répondre en plus du tout il ya tellement
de choses à voir
bon portez vous bien soyez sages et je
vous dis à très bientôt
[Musique]